we're told that in 40 years imran will
be 11 times as old as he is right now
and then we're asked how old is he right
now and so i encouraged you to try this
on your own
well let's see if we can set this up as
an as an equation so let's let's figure
out what our unknown is first well our
unknown is how old he is right now so
let's let let's let and i'm just
arbitrarily using x we always like to
use x but i could have usually said it
to be anything but let's say x is equal
to how old he is right now how old
not how old how old he
is
now
what do we know about how old he will be
in 40 years
well he's going to be how old he is now
plus 40. so let me write that down
so
in
in 40 years
imran is going to be x
plus 40
plus
plus 40 plus this 40 right over here
but they give us another piece of
information this by itself isn't enough
to figure out how old he is right now
but they tell us in 40 years so in 40
years imran will be
imran will be 11 times as old as he is
right now so that's saying that this
quantity right over here x plus 40 is
going to be 11 times x
in 40 years he's going to be 11 times as
old as he is right now so this is going
to be
times 11. you take x multiply it times
11 you're going to get how old he's
going to be in 40 years
so let's write that down as an equation
you take x
multiply it by 11.
so
11 times as old as he is right now
is
how old he is going to be in 40 years
is how old he is going to be
in 40 years and we have set up our a
nice little tidy linear equation now so
we just have to solve for x
so let's get all the x's on the
left-hand side we have more x's here
than on the right-hand side so so we
avoid negative numbers let's take all
the x's here so if i want to get rid of
this x on the right hand side i want to
subtract an x but obviously i can't just
do it to the right otherwise the
equality won't be true anymore i need to
do it on the left as well
and so i am left with
11 if i have 11 of something and i take
away one of them i'm left with 10 of
that something so i'm left with 10
times x
10 times x
is equal to well these x's x minus x is
just zero that was the whole point it's
going to be equal to 40 and you could do
this in your head at this point but
let's just solve it formally so if we
want a one coefficient here we'd want to
divide by 10 but we've got to do that to
both sides and so we are left with and
we can have our drum roll now
we are left with x
is equal to
four years old
x is equal to four so our answer the
question how old is imran right now
he is for
four years old and let's verify this if
he's four years old
right now
in 40 years he's going to be 44
years old
and 44 years old is indeed 11 times
older than 4 years old you definitely
this is a factor of 11 years so it all
worked out